Good faith. Good faith security researches. That's the term.
Best faith.
Best faith security researchers.
I'm going to put that in my Twitter bio now. Best faith security researcher.
Hey everybody, how's it going? Techno Geek here. I just wanted to take a moment to shout out
our episode sponsor, Project Discovery. Project Discovery makes a lot of different hacking
tools. I'm sure you've at least heard of Nuclei, and that's the one we wanted to focus
on today. They just released version 3.2. Now, 3.2 has a ton of awesome new features,
and the two I wanted to highlight are authenticated scanning and the changes to fuzzing support.
Now, authenticated scanning does basically what you'd expect. You can finally now authenticate
into applications automatically with Nuclei. You can leverage either the built-in existing
login templates that they've included, or you can make your own and you can use all of your
old existing Nuclei templates to scan on an authenticated context within an application.
For fuzzing support, they have now expanded the fuzzing from just query parameters all
the way out to headers and cookies and body parameters and paths and everything that you
can imagine. So you're going to want to check out what's in this new release. Again, it's
version 3.2. And if you want to learn more, go to nux.gg slash podcast. Again, that's nux.gg
slash podcast. Thanks.
Dude, why is there a link in this doc of a mobile device server rack?
What is this? Why did you put this in here? What is this?
Okay. So you asked me yesterday, you were like, hey, do you have any interesting links?
Like, do you use Twitter bookmarks? And I was like, I do use Twitter bookmarks, but I don't
think I have anything useful in there. And I opened it up. And the last thing I bookmarked
was this post that I saw.
This is nuts, dude.
And I just found it really interesting. So I think the original thread was sort of like
going through the evolution of like how sort of this phone automation stuff has developed
over the last decade or whatever. And it used to be that you'd have like a real person sitting
in front of like a sheet of plywood with 15 cheap Samsung phones on it or whatever.
And they would just like tap all the buttons on like 30 different screens.
Dude, talk about the most boring job ever.
That was just how it worked.
Like, you just get a message and you're like, all right, like this post on like 50 different
devices. And then you just go around and tap, tap, tap, tap, tap. It's crazy.
Exactly. Exactly. So, but the one that I liked was this, I think it's like the latest generation
or whatever, but like, I'd never seen anything like this. They take real phones and they disassemble
them and they unscrew the main board from inside the device and then they hook it up to some
special PCB that they developed. And they, they do this like 20 times and they mount them inside
of a server case so that there's like 15 of these boards just like sitting on their edge,
just like mounted next to each other, all plugged into this one giant board. And then you take like
a single USB cable from this box and you plug it into your computer and you run this software
and you just have like a display of like, you know, the 30 screens from every single phone
that's mounted inside the server box. It looks like a virtualized...
And you just click once and it clicks everywhere.
Yeah. I love how it clones it to all of them, but it looks like, you know, they're just doing
Android virtualization, but it's like actual physical devices.
Yeah. It's super, super interesting, but I guess this is how they're doing it nowadays with
all the big like bots, botnet type of things or whatever.
Yeah. Yeah. And I was, I was saying like back in my days, so before I'd gotten to bug
gunny and stuff, I used to write bots. And the way that I did this was I just had like a stack of
iPhones that I bought on eBay that I jail broke. We're just like sitting on the floor.
You were the guy with the giant piece of plywood and pressing the buttons, huh?
That's exactly right.
That's hilarious.
I bet that was a pretty, pretty relevant hacking experience though, building bots for, for, you know, things, let's just say.
Yeah. I like, it's very, very similar skill set to bug bounty, just like different implementation.
It's like how I like to see it.
Still got to reverse engineer stuff.
I think that there's a lot of, exactly. It's like that same sort of mindset. Like I would say security is a mindset where like hacking is a mindset where you just have to reframe how you think about like the same sort of problems.
And I think that's a great example of it where like botting and security are like almost identical. It's just how you decide to like use the information that you have, whether you choose to like exploit it for malicious purposes or whether you choose to like.
There's a huge overlap of the community too. So many really talented botters or anti-botters have gone into security afterwards. This is an interesting pipeline.
Yeah, for sure.
And vice versa as well. I've seen people go from security and hacking into the anti-bot space and be like, wow, this is so hard, you know? So.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. Exactly. Every once in a while I get, I get the nerd sniped into that area again.
Yeah. That's probably one of the more, I don't know. I imagine that's one of the more sort of back and forth industries that you've got because like security is a little bit back and forth.
Like sometimes you'll actively be like, oh, this person's literally trying to hack my website right now or like my computer right now.
But like that's that those are kind of kind of rare. But with with botting stuff, I mean, it's like, are they going to bot this drop or not?
You know, like and the answer is always going to be pretty much yes. You know, so they're always going to be trying to figure out how to get around it.
And it's got to be it's probably one of the more tangible cat and mouse games you can find in it.
For sure. It's a really big cat and mouse game. Like that was the biggest thing that sort of like pulled me away from it was just like it was very grindy in that sense where like it's you versus the security team.
And in my opinion, the security team always has an advantage because from the attacker perspective, they have to reverse engineer how all these checks work from the security team's perspective.
They can implement like 10 checks and turn on one of them and then, you know, let it sit. And then the hacker figures out, OK, this is how I bypass one of them.
And then the security team turns on a second one. And then the anti botting thing under the security team normally. Do you know?
Is that like its own division or is it like a. Yeah, I mean, usually it's either under security or like trust and safety type stuff because they're usually like sort of hand in hand with like anti fraud, anti botting that type of. Interesting.
Well, this is the last time I'm letting you put a link in the dock.
I can't show you all. I open this up and it's just like a rack full of mobile phones. The most Joel thing I could possibly.
Yeah, wait till you see what I bookmark next month. That's great, man.
All right, dude. Major life lesson here for any of those listening and for you and for me.
When Shubs tweets something. You listen to the tweet. I'm a simple man.
When Shubs tweets, I listen, you know, and Shubs tweeted out earlier this week about I as he said, let me just let me just read what he said.
I can't believe so many people are sleeping on this research. Here's the link.
Here's the link. And when he says something like that, you got to not sleep on that because that's serious.
And lo and behold, I took the deep dive. I read it and he is correct.
We were fast asleep on this whole or at least I was. I was fast asleep on this dot net remoting research that just came out from code.
What is it? Code white. Code white. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So it's interesting because most of the time when the asset note team or Shubs is tweeting about something, it's some zero day that they've reverse engineered or found and they have like a big blog post.
This was different. This was just like a blog post. And not only that, it was like a month old.
It was it wasn't like, oh, this came out three days ago.
Like when he says sleeping like this account, this had been out for maybe over a month.
Next time, next time, tweet it out. Just about a month. Tweet that out right away. As soon as it comes out, just be like, hey, this is amazing. Everyone should look at this. But yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's super, super interesting. And it the what's cool is it's not even the first one in this sort of like series like Code White had done another blog post two years ago in 2022 about this same sort of technology from sort of a different perspective.
And it's called dot net remoting. So I know that you actually. I popped something with it last night.
Yeah. Yeah. So tell me a little bit about that because I think we have something special for the. Yeah. Yeah. So there's there's a lot of of cool things. Cool takeaways from this one.
I'm going to give a high level overview of what this sort of concept is here. And and then we'll kind of go into the new research that came out.
So dot net remoting is essentially if you guys are familiar with Java RMI remote method invocation, it's very similar to that. But essentially it allows you to call functions and expose objects.
So let me be more clear to your code on a different server and it runs that code on that server rather than in your your local code base.
And so you can register these various classes to be able to be triggered remotely.
And then you have the ability to call those classes over TCP, IPC or HTTP.
And so there's a couple resources. We'll create a section in the show notes on the best resources I could find on this.
They got me up to speed on it enough to pop an RC last night or multiple RCs last night.
But and essentially, you know, you have those three ways of exploiting it.
And but the problem was previously before this research came out in order to exploit this over HTTP, which is the one that has the least, you know, security controls on it and the one that is most likely to be exposed due to HTTP services often being exposed.
You needed to know this like arbitrary string in the URL that gets generated when these objects get created.
And if you know this arbitrary string, then you can access the that interface and get it to run instantiate these objects and run code.
Yeah, got it.
So the problem then is how do we get this URL?
How do we get this URL? And that is what this amazing research that Shubs highlighted and Marcus Wolfe Tang, I hope I pronounced that correctly, was writing about when he released this leaking object references to exploit HTTP.NET
So the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that
there's a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of
the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was a lot of the first thing that was
I don't know did I put it in the doc I okay let me go find it right now I'll put it in the doc but they leak they have this awesome GitHub repo that just makes it super simple to go and exploit this and it's in this like little note at the end of the yeah it's literally the last line of the of the article it says we also released this GitHub repo HTTP remoting object ref leak with additional resources such as a vulnerable web app and some pay example exploit
payloads and a script for automated object ref leaking and payload delivery
dude
this is a python scripted here it's literally less than 100 lines and it's just like
yeah dude I love that and I just love I just I messaged Marcus on on Twitter and I said dude thank you for being so thorough with this write-up and then also delivering you know like a beautiful exploit to GitHub and thank you also for putting it at the very end of this article
so that I most people will skip it if they get intimidated by this article and then only I will find it and then I will use it to pop bugs because that's what happened last night because I hit Noggle up I was like I understand this research scan for this scan for that and he he ran you know a scan across his whole you know empire of of subdomains or whatever and we got a couple hits and we popped some RCs so
that's so awesome that's so awesome and what's cool is so at the very end initially this actually didn't have a CVE this was just like some research that was just published in a blog back in February and a week ago a little under a week ago
Microsoft reassessed it and they published a CVE for it and it was addressed in the January
let's see the CVE was addressed by updates in January 2024 but the CVE was
omitted from the security updates so I am wondering if that maybe is how Shubs picked up on this
because this was on March 22nd when the CVE was released by Microsoft and maybe
maybe the team over there is just keeping a close eye on
but Shubs is also yeah I feel like Shubs is also like a shark with this stuff so like anytime anything IIS or .NET related you know comes up he's like sure you know it's like a it's like a piranha in the water you know to those sort of things
sorry to represent you that way Shubs but it's like I mean he just he knows all the things about IIS related stuff and .NET related stuff so any of that Windows HTTP stack
things so I wouldn't be surprised if he was on top of this as soon as it came out
yeah I do love how how much like sort of it's not necessarily new research right like it is but it isn't like the core research itself is but a lot of the stuff that is based on like the blog from Saroosh for example
that blog is now five years old from the NCC group one from Saroosh and talking about this same sort of technology that even their previous blog post from Code White
was two years old so it's really interesting I mean we talked about this over and over again that just because something is a couple years old research wise doesn't mean that it's out of date or
irrelevant or not applicable and taking the time to read through those research even if it's you know five years old you see something five years old and you're like oh well this probably won't apply today it probably does actually and you should read through it
yeah absolutely and and I always love when people continue to build on their past research because you know the the Code White team at this point after having done this in in what did you say two years ago so 2022
you know they have a knowledge set on this on this topic that is you know very exclusive to them and maybe a couple other people in the world you know and so they they are carrying the burden of like all right if there's going to be innovation in this area it should probably be me
you know and they continue to build upon that research and build upon that research until they find a way like this to leak these these object references and and get access to that that secret URL very cool I really like it
yeah super super cool awesome should we go to the the next the next link yeah hit me with it man okay so this is this is a fun one this doesn't happen almost ever there was a Dom purifier
there was a Dom purifier so it was it this is always juicy because I woke up a couple days ago and somebody in our one of our mutual group chats had posted his life babe wake up the new Dom purifier
so I passed just dropped just dropped and I was like whoa that's crazy and there's a really really cool blog from um oh what's their name I literally just had it open
uh slancer yeah that's it yeah slancer both on twitter and and their blog slancer underscore um and their blog is blog.slancer.info
so essentially this is a bit of a niche bypass um the main thing here is that it has to do with passing in uh element object into the Dom purify um sanitize function so you can both pass in a string that is just like HTML
just like HTML and it will sanitize that or you can pass in an actual object reference like if you do like document.create element you can pass that actual variable into Dom purify sanitize and it'll do the same thing
and one of the interesting things that he noticed is that when it basically back parses or forward parses whatever converts it into a string or from a string into the actual element nodes
it checks the types of the elements and does certain processing on every single one and there it has the capability to sanitize and parse XML as well as HTML and there are some core key differences between XML and HTML when it's getting parsed and when it's getting rendered by the browser
and individually and so what this researcher found is that if you pass in these special XML tags you know how XML has like the the open arrow question mark and it does like open arrow question mark and sets the you know what version it is
there's a couple there's a couple weird tags in XML right there's like the what is it the ones we use for for xxe all the time the cdata ones and then there's also these are like uh these are processing instruction tags right
right yeah so they're they're referred to specifically as processing instructions and you can basically think the thing of them as sort of like metadata that really just tells
tells the processor how it's you know how it's you know how it's processing instructions right it tells it how it should be processed rather than you know directly just sort of inferring a lot of that stuff
um and so dom purify has to handle this and the way that it does handle this is by essentially replacing those tags with html comment tags
right and so you have a little bit of a confusion here where it's going from xml to html in the rendering in the sanitization process where it's sort of passively just say oh
this should be treated as html but as we mentioned there are core differences between how xml and html are
both interpreted and rendered by the browser so when you put this stuff inside of like an svg tag for example
you can do all sorts of really fun things and the tldr is that if you open with these processing uh instructions
and then you just leave an empty closing arrow or closing you know bracket in there or whatever it the
it doesn't properly sanitize it and so it allows you to escape that into an html context and you can
insert you know in image elements that trigger on error and all that kind of stuff just directly within
the svg um actually not within the svg outside of the svg let's you break out of the svg huh yeah super super
interesting um and i think part of the root cause at least in the beginning was the fact that when it
filters through the element nodes that it's that that you feed into the sanitize function it has
selectors for specific types like should it allow comments should it allow elements should it allow
processing instructions and processing instructions was not um enabled by default and so what you know
it caused it to sort of have this behavior where it wasn't handling it correctly it was handling it in
a very specific way uh as if it was like html and so that was the initial fix and then i think that
the there was actually a bypass um just based on sort of like how dom furify is configurable you can
have these different checks uh that look for different tag names and stuff and you can again
you can bypass it um using a similar sort of you know you use a custom tag name and you do the same
sort of attack where you close it early um and you can get it to you know pull pull this custom data out
of the elements and uh and again trigger a custom tag name instead of the the processing instructions
for okay gotcha yeah yeah it uses this yeah it has this like special custom element handling configuration
thing and one thing i will note is i think i think they actually mentioned this as well this isn't super
common like the configuration in the use case here but it is still a bypass and it's still really really
interesting data and i think you actually mentioned that we won't name them but somebody that you know and i
i know i did uh managed to actually find some bypasses i did get permission so uriota uh urio tuck
i guess is his handle uh but rio is his name he uh he saw this and he's you know just the brain just
starts spinning and spinning and spinning and so he he actually found some some bypasses to this as well
so this is uh you know one a bypass then a another bypass and a fix and then uriota also has some some
bypasses so this um this processing instructions thing seems to have been the the core of a lot of
really tricky functionality as far as html parsing goes and html synthesization goes so i bet in other
libraries there's also similar problems if they're also including uh ht or xml with the html when they're
trying to do the sanitization so definitely definitely some cool takeaways there and the processing
instruction thing i i wasn't familiar with this i didn't think until i realized that sorry the processing
instruction uh that you see at the beginning of every single xml blob you know like if you're going to do an xxc it's is like you know
know yeah angle bracket question mark yeah xml yeah and it likes to find that this is like an xml
document and you can define like the the um like utf-8 or whatever yeah encoding and stuff and so
you see it almost all the time i just hadn't really been like oh what is that yet so i'm glad for people
like slauncer that that are think oh what is that and go research it and find cool stuff like this because
this is definitely a really sweet bypass yeah exactly and and maybe something for the listener
it i do wonder how this works for other things like php i think is a great example which also does a
similar thing where it has those sort of like processing not really processing instructions but
like that prefix type of stuff and perhaps other similar instances of this behavior may also be vulnerable
to bad implementations or um you know like weird tricky situations like this where you can feed
double tags and get it to parse yeah for sure dude i'm looking forward to seeing um yota's write up he's
gonna release it within the next couple weeks so i'm excited for that bad boy awesome awesome yeah i
love uh it's awesome i mean the cure 53 team that in the blog it says that they fixed it like same day
always i mean like almost immediately um so super cool i know i think we know at least one person over
on that team um who's doing really cool stuff so shout out to the cure 53 team shout out to dom
purify super awesome uh you know even even when they make a little mistake they're uh they address
it very elegantly as much as i i love the dom purify team man it hurts me on a on a on a weekly basis to
see their their tool properly implemented in so many places it's like no it's top here fight give up
you know so it is everybody every bug hunter streams to get like a a dom a dom purified bypass it is
that's on the like uh you what are the bug hunter bingo chart or whatever like all right let me dom
purify bypass rce you know zero day that i can spray across hack of my whack bypass well and also so
speaking of laughs we'll just jump down a little bit to the to the second last item on the on the list here
um so i was poking around on a target the other day and i i i don't know why i've seen this endpoint
like 50 bajillion times but the whole um cloudflare slash cdn dash cgi thing kind of stood out to me
because it's like okay essentially what's happening here is um you've got cloud fair in front it's a waft
and then you know that waft needs to have some client-side resources so that it can do things like
uh you know enforce a captcha or something like that excuse me and uh and so what it does is it
injects this endpoint slash cdn dash cgi on all of the you know websites it protects and then it hosts
its own custom stuff there like js files and and that sort of thing um logging endpoints and that sort
of thing um so i was looking at this i'm like wow this is uh super weird and i feel like if we can hack
this then we can hack like every website you know uh because every website that has cloudflare has this
on in front of it and so i started researching it and there's like um a documentation endpoint
uh or documentation endpoint man so such such hacker terminology there dude uh a documentation page
on um on you know what this endpoint is and essentially it lists five um uses for this endpoint it says
okay you can hit cdn cgi slash trace which one is super cool because it like kicks back information
about your request and it's in like text plain content type but um that could be helpful for
something for sure um so there's that uh there's javascript detection uh that's the that's the bot
product thing uh that that prevents bonding um there's image transformations which i was like okay
okay now we're talking here so i i so like there's ways that you can like do tr like um uh transforming
of images and converting of images and i went in here and it's like supported input formats svg
supported output formats svg and i was like that's interesting so i i went in there and i was like poking
around at it for a long time and i was like man i wonder if there's any you know any bugs here any ways
to bypass and i was actually thinking like okay svg xml like we just talked about the dom purify bypass
let me see if i can like try some cool stuff with that so i was like writing that out wasn't working
and of course who do i turn to the master of cloud flare mr uriota himself that we just talked about
and and it was like oh yeah i i assessed that like you know months ago uh there's a super duper tight
uh freaking csp on it i was like shoot so i went there and i looked and lo and behold it's like
default source none which is like like what are you gonna be able to do with that um and and so
the svg endpoint might be a little bit of a dead end but there's also a bunch of other things here and
there have been bugs found here before by the the port swigger team um back in 2017 and then also by our
boy uh masato kinugawa um found a like global csp bypass on any website that uses uh cloud flare back
in uh 2017 and i just haven't i researched around and i haven't seen a bunch of research on this specific
endpoint since like you know 2017-ish time so i feel like it's time to look at this again because i feel
like there could be some csp bypasses here um and at least if not csp bypasses at least some cool gadgets
that could be used to hack some stuff in some pretty nice circumstances we just got to enumerate
every single file that is or every single endpoint that's under that slash cdn cgi place
yeah for sure um it's cool to see this tweet all the way back from august 2017 this is i think even
before i started bug bounty because i started in august of 2017 at like a live hacking event so uh this
this is probably like a couple weeks before i even started doing bug bounty but it's really cool to see
um just the sort of you know you're talking about the one from masato it's like yeah yeah yeah yeah this
tweet just being like hey by the way here's like a cloudflare csp bypass that i found like weird
behavior um and it it reminds me a lot of this other link um from malloc on twitter that was talking about
these xss that that um that he found where this cdn uh of of the of the target of the of the program
um is like cdn.example.com or whatever and that's explicitly out of scope but while they were looking
at in scope targets they noticed that there was a lot of endpoints that would use a slash version of
it where they would go you know example.com slash cdn um slash file.js or whatever and because of that
uh by popping something on the cdn by finding an available file that they could upload and
and essentially control they were able to use that same path scheme to pull their attacker controlled
file from the cdn directly and get nexus on all these different domains and that just reminds me so much
of this cdn cgi endpoint because it's very very so i wonder if it might even have been real sketchy man
and and like it it makes you think like okay especially in this i've seen this scenario a bunch
of times where it's like okay they're reverse proxying to their cdn and like they're saying it's out of
scope but actually we can just upload any file that we've uploaded to the cdn we can just access on any
given host i've seen that plenty of times before um so that's a great general principle but also this
concept of like reverse proxying to cdns you know in the cloudflare scenario in in this scenario that
malik is talking about it's sketchy man it's it's sketchy because you know cdns they're supposed to
host content you know and and if that content can be affected by other users you're just letting
people upload arbitrary content to be hosted potentially on any other website that uses that
same cdn if there's a reverse proxy yeah for sure and i think it's really interesting um i mean like
just that behavior in general like the path routing to like subdomains and stuff is super weird like
that screams reverse proxy problems secondary context problems all sorts of weird things so um you know
that's one of those things to keep an eye out for like definitely probably more than xss you could you
could find a lot more it's a great point another thing that i've kind of seen with this format
is like what will happen is sometimes these cdns need to be are like signed url protected or whatever
right and you need to get uh assigned url for anything and but when you're accessing it via like
a a certain path on a website it's just using like whatever god token or whatever that gives it access to
that that s3 bucket or whatever that back end is and um one if you can cause some sort of error and
get it to leak that uh token then that's big bucks um but two if you can just do a path traversal if you
can get the the reverse proxy to normalize um and and hit a password so it's a little bit tricky with s3
because s3 doesn't do do traversals um but if you can figure out a way to get that to to work and you
can hit any endpoint without having to you know have assigned url or auth associated with it then a lot of
times there's a lot of sensitive information you can leak as well yeah for sure i i love that token
leaking thing because we've seen that many times at live hacking events where it's not even like a crazy
complex bug it's it's it's almost like a stack trace it's like crazy you know like the the least
suspecting thing that you would you would think to become like a super critical bug but all it takes is
that you know it's that one token or that one over privileged method of access and uh an accidental
error trace and and it's gg i'll never forget this one time like there was an endpoint that a couple
people found that was allowing you to do some traversing and that sort of thing um and uh on a
back-end host and you could access files you weren't supposed to be able to access and it was like it was
like very impactful it was definitely you know a higher crit already and then noggly comes along
and he just i don't know being the big brain boy he is he like sticks a collaborator you know domain in
there in like a spot that doesn't make any sense to put it in right and somehow he gets a hit on that
domain instead of on the actual like back-end host and then that that that you know hit the ssrf hit
you couldn't do like um like full read or anything but that ssrf hit had the auth token for that that back
server attached to it you use that auto could log into that back that back-end server and you can
just dump everything which is so much more impactful because you didn't need to know the url you know
the path of the thing that we were trying to leak on the back end that's so interesting another place
where i see this type of pattern a lot is mobile apps actually where a lot of times for mobile
app authentication right typically it's not cookies it's like an auth token or something like that
like a header and um they forget to add an auth check and so they just add it like they have it
added at sort of a middleware level across the entire request hdp client that they're using and it'll just
add it to everything because they assume oh this is just going to all our trusted hosts but if you can
find a way to control the host or you know make it redirect or something like that well we've talked
about reading a little bit but depending on how it's how it's implemented um yeah that one still
hurts a little bit man but um but a lot of the times it'll get added automatically and all you have
to do is be able to control the host and you get a full account takeover because that off that off token
or that off cookie or whatever is getting set on every single request and all you have to do is be
able to control where that request is going and it's that that's big it's almost like client-side
path traversal um for the client side of the mobile apps right yeah yep yeah exactly which we've also
seen we have so it just i don't know man i hate to because it it's helpful to categorize all these
different things you know like client-side path traversal and like you know srf and bloody blah but at the
end of the day it's like look if you could make something hit your server and you know be aware
of the context in which that can happen you know like that can happen in the browser it can happen
you know in the victim's browser it can happen in the uh you know the mobile app or the server and then
just read everything you know about that request that you can possibly read um and look at all the
hints look at all the little tokens look at all the cookies that are getting passed along because um
there's a decent chance that something could be really sensitive there yeah yeah yeah absolutely
all right let's see what do we got i want you i want you to talk about xss doctor because there was
some really awesome uh collaboration that happened in the critical thinkers channel on the discord and uh
and it led to a blog post and a couple other things so why don't you talk about doctor was um
such a valued member of the critical thinking community was chatting in the in the critical
thinkers chat on the discord and he was talking about he's like oh guys i found this like really
cool way to like reverse uh javascript uh de obvious or javascript obfuscation um and i was like dude
you gotta write this up like this is helpful for somebody this is exactly what we talk about on the pod
all the time which is like look even if it isn't a crazy vuln if you spent some time and you figured
something out then um and you're so inclined you know i'm not gonna tell everybody to write up
everything but like and you're so inclined write that up it has a lot of value to share things like
that because um you know people can build on the back of that just like we saw with the dot net
remoting thing how you know the the code white team built on the show you know on the back of saroosh
and then they built on their own stuff and it just it keeps on building and building and building and
the more we can sort of help foster that environment it's really good so i said um listen jd you gotta you
gotta write this up so he wrote it up and he's he's got it uh got it posted on medium we'll link it
down in the description but essentially what he uh did was he released a script and sort of explained
what was going on with a very common uh js obfuscation scheme and essentially what it is is they
those jerks take all all the strings everything helpful from a javascript file and they just stick it
in one massive array right and then they say to themselves okay how can i make this as complicated
as possible and so they make this like decryption function that that's like okay we're gonna take
in a hex value not a not a not a decimal value a hex value just just to be a little and uh and then
we're gonna we're gonna do a certain amount of like shifts and pushes you know to like rotate the
order of this array uh this many times and then we're gonna do some math and then we're gonna like
you know spit out a value from this array and that's the the thing you're looking for you know in
this sort of obfuscation scheme yeah and um and so essentially jd very painstakingly stepped through
all of that explained how all this works and how common of a of a js obfuscation scheme this is uh
a sort of format this is and he includes a script on how to um how to unobfuscate um with scripts that
use this this method and he showed me the results of uh you know the before and after of the script
and man does it increase readability um in these sort of super obfuscated situations uh so i think
this is really helpful for anybody who's dealing with highly obfuscated js
yeah and i love i love the sort of the basic simple knowledge sharing aspect that you talked
about i mean like we do that i mean that's how this podcast is just like us talking about like
random little things and tips and tricks and stuff that we've come across and learned throughout the
years of doing bug bounty and having you know other people just sort of write those things down and share
it is so valuable because the same people who are listening to this podcast also want to consume that
data right they want those little tips and tricks that they can put in their in their notebook or
put in the back of their head and then when they encounter something like that they can say oh i have
a thing for that let me let me go you know i don't need to waste my time figuring out how this works
let me just read that exercise doctor blog post really quick and and uh and do the same thing and
make this easier and cut to the chase um the other thing is i see this all the time again in mobile apps
uh mobile apps i do this all the time a string obfuscation um and i imagine you could probably
do a similar thing in javascript what i like to do in um in android is i just use frida and i hook and i
call the function directly and i just pass in the obfuscated string that i have in the source code and
um i'll just you know take the the decoded or decrypted output or whatever and i'll just replace it in
the source so that i can know what it is the other thing i'll sometimes do is i'll hook it um and i'll
either replace the function with like a wrapper or something like that and i'll just log all the
inputs and outputs and say oh this this obfuscated input equals this deobfuscated output and then
either i can do a match and replace throughout my entire source and i can replace all the instances of
it or if i'm you know i come across something encrypted instead of having to run that function
manually i can just control that for it in the output of you know my console or whatever and i can see
yeah the wrapper is a good idea and he mentioned something in there too it's like okay so this
function is called you know a3c or whatever right and and sometimes they call it a3c directly but
sometimes they'll do like let cd equal a3c and then they'll call cd or something like that it's like
come on could you just like could you not could you please not do that yeah exactly so that's the
one thing about the wrapper right the wrapper if you wrap that that underlying function then
regardless of how it gets called then it's still gonna log it um so that's pretty nice but yeah
obfuscation is always just it's one of those security through obscurity things that i never
really agree with because it uh like what is it doing it's making it more difficult to understand
what's going on from an outside perspective but there's no actual like security implications there
right like you're not making it from a back inside like if you're trying to prevent somebody from abusing
your apis then prevent them from abusing your apis from the api side right add server-side checks add
additional verification methods all sorts of stuff that make it more difficult to abuse the apis
don't just make it more difficult to read um but maybe that's my naive no no no i mean like look look
dude i i i want to agree with you and don't get me wrong in a report many times i i have i have
dissed security by absurdity and be like you can't rely on security by obscurity you know like very
passionately arguing for security uh or against uh security by obscurity but recently i'm realizing
like listen so much of this industry um you know at its core is just about not being the easiest target
to to pop right you know like that's like and i think most of the people that are running back bounty
programs are already kind of beyond that point i'd imagine you know where it's like they're not the
easiest you know one to get into or whatever but um just riddle me this joel you know riddle me this
joel if you're hacking a target and you put wrong one wrong parameter and it returns a 404 how does that
make you feel that makes you feel terrible doesn't it when when there's no error page it's certainly not
a good feeling for you know there's no 500 error there's no 400 there's no like 403 am i not
authorized who knows it's just a 404 you know how about why how about wildcard supplements man and so
it's like it's like you know anything you can do like that you know js obfuscation 404 uh you know
error pages and stuff like that rather than actual 500s or whatever or or 403s even right like
they you're when when you do a 403 you're letting the attacker know hey you're not authorized to do
this you know and that that gives them information where you could just say yeah don't know you know
and so do you think that there's a remedy for this from like to to make it easier for security
researchers though because like on one hand like from it from for attackers like yeah it's dangerous
um to not have those things in place when like someone's coming from malicious intent perspective but
then if you have sort of that best intent perspective and you want to make it easier for
researchers like what do you is there do you have any tips any ideas best intent not not good intent
you know normally the the phrase is like good intent security research but we we have the best intent
but uh yeah um yeah so i think pretty much the only solution to that from this perspective is like having
a private vip program if you're a public program because if you're a public program you can't
release to everyone like hey just add this header and it'll like turn all the 404s into 500s or
whatever right yeah that's crazy you know the hackers are just gonna be like thank you very much
you know i am a security researcher that's right i have lost my way um but yeah if you run a private
vip program with the people that are going to be adding the most value to your to your program with
vetted you know people on it you know hacker one background checked or whatever and have a track
record of being you know best in 10 security researchers um then not just good but the best
um yeah no good faith good good faith security reasons that's the that's the term best security
researchers i'm gonna i'm gonna put that advice i'm gonna put that in my twitter bio now best the
best faith security researcher um i'm not even good i'm just the best yeah so anyway uh then then you
can release you know some sort of header or something that's gonna undo all that and you can release
you know on a piece kdjs files and stuff like that so i don't know man it's a little bit of a it's a
little bit of a trade-off obviously all of that takes time and effort away from actually securing
the product as well right because at the end of the day uh it's not that hard to sort of intuit how
some of this dysfunctionality is going to be working you know if there's like an id parameter
and id parameter you know equals you know somebody's id and then you put in somebody else's id if it's not
a 403 it's a 200 then you have to return to 200 you know at the end of the day you're still going to
run into issues like that so um whether it's worth it or not i'm not sure but um it definitely pisses
me off so i imagine it pisses off other hackers me too yeah absolutely okay we have two we have two
more tweets and i wanted to save um naffy's for the end uh to discuss that so let's go over um randy pox
um cool little technique here i think this is this is just one of those little gadgets for like
proving impact i think that's that's just a nice little i wanted to ask you about this joel because
um so renapack tweeted to make your xss less conspicuous you can hide your payload by updating
url path of the valid url and i think this is just something a lot of people don't know you can do
so if you run history.push state and as a third parameter provide a path it will stay on the same
page that you're on um you know like you you will remain in control of the dom but the path will be
updated the path and url bar will be updated to whatever you provide it and that's just pretty
weird yeah for sure and you see this you see this actually on a lot of websites without probably even
realizing it um basically anything that's changing your your url without a full page load or a redirect
is doing this um i think youtube does this a lot how all the single page applications work
yeah all the single page applications are using you know push uh local street push
whatever the function is yeah and so and so i don't know i wanted to talk to you about this like
um one i think a great tweet really helpful uh brings brings light to something that a lot of
people might not be aware of um being possible uh but also like i feel like there's a whole set of like
attacker-like practices like this that you can implement into your pocs that just bring more impact
and what i've realized lately is like when you model a full attack path and you make it extremely clear
um that hits harder with the team i i have a bug that recently got paid 150 of what it normally would
get paid because we we found a bug similar to this many times and you know we submit it they always pay
the same amount for it every time but this time i was like all right let me take this a little bit
further i'm gonna explain how i would distribute this payload given you know the functionality on the
website i'm gonna explain how um i would exploit this once the user you know uh clicks on the link or
whatever um and how you know how i would worm it essentially um so i described that and it got paid
150 what it normally gets paid um and so i think there's this whole concept of like making your attacks
have more visual impact that i think is a little bit underestimated and i might might have been and i do
pretty good pocs and like i i that's what something that i consider to be my one of my my strong points
but i think you can even take it even further and describe the whole attack path um and how you would
exploit this at a scale and i think that will really increase impact yeah yeah for sure i mean i think um
it really depends on the program right so some programs are really good about saying like we know what
impact is like we can we can tell that from this point here's what the ultimate impact would be of
your vulnerability we're going to pay it out as such however i would say that's not the norm most
programs probably aren't going to do that most programs are going to say here's the impact you
demonstrated we're going to pay you as such um you know if you have an xss but you don't show that you
can steal cookies and do an ato they're going to pay it as an xss not an ato right um because i mean
for a lot of reasons right like it's not never it's not really in their best interest to escalate a
vulnerability for you like even further like they probably know that that that issue is there um but
you know from from the research research researchers perspective you want to sort of demonstrate
um the highest impact you can so that is also sort of that benefit of hacking on one program is that you
develop those gadgets and those impact scenarios yourself where you can say oh anytime i have an
excess i can create an ato like they have this systemic problem or um whatever it is and you
can demonstrate that that impact um in other cases it might not you know be worth it right like for the
time and effort or whatever it takes to to escalate that vulnerability further like versus just like
having you know if you know the program and you know that they're going to handle it well spending
an extra four hours or something to try and escalate your your xss to some you know further bug may
not be worth the effort right it's the juice worth the squeeze is the phrase that i always like um
and so i think it you know it kind of depends program by program but you should always try and
you know if you have the ability to put a higher impact scenario i mean imagine right like if you
have an xss and you have an ato why would you only report the exercise right you're always going to
report the higher impact scenario so if you have those easy opportunities yeah yeah if you have
those easy easy opportunities like chase them down you know hedge your time and stuff so that
you're you're not spending too much time on something that's not worth it but you know escalate
your bugs as best as you can and then when you feel like you're there go ahead and submit it
and uh that's that's always my recommendation but not this is something nogli does well which which
just eeks eeks be a little bit oh yeah um 100 percent freaking eeks me a little bit man because
like whenever we collab he's like justin why why aren't you writing a good report what you need to
write a better report for them to like yeah his titles his title is like pre-auth full rce access to
source code and and it's like like success you're like you know like and he does he does take it a
little over the top sometimes but he tells a good story you know and he and he and he outlines the
attack path so and i think what what random pack did here was like he provided another way for you
to make it seem more like an actual attack and you know if you look in your in your url bar and there's
like you know script bloody bloody blah you know then it might not be the most um uh you know convincing
attack uh but if you if you update that using history.push state then it can make something look
very benign and uh you know people cannot even realize they're on a certain page uh so
it's it's right it's it's definitely a a good technique and there's other things as well like
um like closing your your sort of um conspicuous windows after you do see surfs with them and not
just leaving it open on the like you know company's successfully updated object page or whatever yeah
um that sort of thing um and i think just like i said before it just feels good to give a fully
polished poc and i think um for those of you that haven't fully fully fleshed out like a
banger of a poc before you should give it a shot because it feels amazing to submit that report and
see your work sort of manifest before you yeah and also from the program side it's it's really nice
when you can just like click one link and see the full impact there right like when a researcher says
step one click this link step two ato like that's yeah awesome right and so like both the satisfaction
for you as well as the program of like there's no question in anybody's mind what the impact is here
what the bug is here like it is very very clear that this is a vulnerability and that it's exploitable
and that it has impact and that's just going to make your triage process faster it's going to make
the payout process faster it's going to make your experience um communicating with the program team
faster and easier and better like everything's just better so if you have a banger poc
do it do it like do it make it as good as you can and always put out the best poc you can because
and like the the flip side the converse is you you create a poc that's like lackluster and there's
like 10 15 steps you're going to be going back and forth to triage trying to get them to reproduce it
you're going to be going back and forth with the program trying to get them to understand the impact and
how it works like it make everybody's life easier your own included and put a put a great poc together
that's my recommendation um so where do we want to go with with the with the naffy's naffy's tweet
you want to you want to launch that one off or should i launch that one off sure sure sure well i'll
read it and then i know you had a question about so um naffy made a tweet um this was a week ago um and
he said i think the idea of keeping it simple is especially true for web testing long before you start
trying to implement complex techniques you need to get down get down the basics of one what are the
assets recon subdomains ip ranges two what can i see on those assets brute forcing are the apis how
are they reached is it brute forceable etc when naffy first started hacking yahoo's all that he used to
do he would run nmap and dirt search for days and find random ass directories that were old legacy apps
and hack on those apps and he said that there's nothing wrong with the complexity but i have largely
remained immune to the movements of application security this is the most significant thing i think
i've added to my methodology for the last years is checking for secondary context traversals if
you're doing just those two things well with any kind of volume or repetition repetition you should
be finding things i know that i still do and i'm largely doing the same things yeah so so go ahead
this is not where i thought he was going with this tweet right if you read it in the beginning he
says and this is where the tweet cuts off right he says long before you start trying to
implement complex techniques you need to get down the basics of and then the tweet cuts right and it
goes to like the the next tweet i was like okay yeah all right naffy like like you tell him and then
i clicked into that tree and he's like recon and i'm like okay okay you know okay i see that and i
know that naffy's a really like recon heavy dude and he does and man is he like one of the most talented
recon guys out there like he really just yep i saw him i worked with him a little bit on a live
hacking event once on an older company specifically on an older company and he's just like really really
coming up with good stuff um yeah and i think recon is important understanding um you know what assets
there are to attack but to i think before you do all that you know you need to get down the basics of
hacking you know you you need to get down the basics of like okay once i find these assets what am
i going to do with them and and like uh how do i how do i find an excess how do i find an access control
thing and like and like yeah i think i think there's there's very clearly multiple types of
hackers even more so than i used to used to think so and the results are really excellent for both
you know like you get the the j haddicks and the naffy type um where they're they're really just like
going heavy on the recon going heavy on the scanning going heavy on this on the um you know
brute forcing the the subdom or the um directories and that sort of thing finding all the apis i like
how naffy called out apis here are there apis how are they reached how are they accessible that's a
good call out um yep but there's those kind of people and then there's the people that are you know
working on the business logic of the applications and i just feel like working on the business logic
of the applications is a better place to start what do you what do you think about that
yeah for sure i so i what i liked about this like i read this and i pulled sort of different different
conclusions that naffy did from from his own tweet right so naffy was like oh you should do like do
recon like you figure out the assets like are they brute forceable and stuff like yeah like kind of but
that's like that's the recon approach right and i think if you're naffy and you hunt like naffy
that is the right place to approach it that is the right that is the right way and i also think
naffy's oversimplifying his own process by saying you know like oh is this brute forceable are there
patterns like that takes decades of context and experience that naffy has that makes it really really
easy for him to do that and he does that really well because of that so when he looks at an api and
he goes oh there's like a weird pattern here like that clicks for him immediately that's not going
to click for everybody immediately when you see sort of these routing things that just is from years
and years and years of him uh looking at different apis especially legacy ones right the stuff that
he's really good at hacking on and identifying those common patterns um and being able to exploit them
really efficiently yeah what i like about his tweet is the keep it simple aspect right and i think a lot
of time myself included um when i'm approaching a target i way over complicate my my like hacking
methodology like i'm trying way outside the box techniques i'm trying all these crazy edge case
like oh maybe this is possible maybe this is possible let me try this crazy thing that is fine
sometimes and a lot of times that will end up end up being a bug but it's a lot more um sort of like
shot in the dark than it needs to be and i like that concept of keeping it simple and identifying what
you're dealing with like what are the assets same thing but more like web application like so what
are the parameters um what are the technologies is json is it xml uh is it is it web-based the apis
thing still applies right are there apis great question um can you brute force it is there a wath
how does it handle when you give it an array instead of a string like all these types of different
things um understanding the different pieces and we've talked about this like as you go deep on a
target you build out sort of a mental mesh uh or map of what what the target is how it works the
different pieces that connect to each other and what things talk to what and how data travels from
one part of the application to another part of the application um and i think that is potentially more
useful than doing sort of that like the recon approach is almost completely separate but different
right it's the same but but but different where yes you're understanding the basics from like
uh architecture level versus you're understanding the basics from an application level um and i think
like keeping it simple and just understanding the fundamentals of what you're hacking on is good
regardless of how you're doing it whether that's figuring out how the routing is working from a dns level
or figuring out how the routing is working from a patho you know this is this is this is a deep this is
a deep one dude you know because there's a couple there's a couple things here like like you
mentioned there's this whole concept of recon within the the main app too you know understanding
where the apis are in the main app where you know how data flows how the js looks like there's
there's internal recon as well um app internal recon that i think is very important in applying those
same principles of what nafi does here as a as a recon hacker um as a wide scale recon hacker to
um hacking inside an application those concepts are very applicable what where are the paths um you know
uh where you know what parameters are they taking just like you said i really like that that's really good
the other thing that's kind of struck me as i'm talking about this is like
maybe maybe maybe i'm playing it safe maybe the reason why i like
hacking the main app is because there's always functionality there there's always there's always
impact there and that's for certain whereas with recon it kind of feels like a big question mark to
me you know it's like it's like am i going to find an asset okay is that asset going to have anything
that i can i can touch on it you know like without off um or can i figure out a way to off into it you
know okay is there any functionality on this weird host in the middle of nowhere you know can i guess the
parameters can i guess the path you know just there's so many question marks for me but you do
see people like nafi and shubs pop these in in corbin for that matter pop these these crazy crits
crits because they find some back-end admin host that has no auth and those kind of crits are not
crits to be perfectly honest that i run across ever because i'm not i'm not doing that yeah um
um and so i don't know man i'm gonna put some more thought into that from from uh a hacker perspective
because it kind of reminds me like it kind of reminds me of the whole um salaryman is not the
word in english that's a japanese word but it's like uh you know the the traditionally employed the
w2 employee versus the entrepreneur right it's like there's so many questions there's so much
uncertainty there's so much struggle that goes into the entrepreneur life um you know versus this
really stable really consistent always going to have your bills paid money that that comes from a w2
um but for me the trade-off has been great you know i i've loved it i i i've i've been able to push
that uncertainty and really enjoy being an entrepreneur or a self-employed so maybe and it kind of
see do you see the parallel that i'm trying to make there between like yeah yeah i totally see the
parallel i think like for recon the interesting thing about recon is yeah the interesting thing about
recon is it's not like what almost every recon bug i found has been basically entirely separated from the
main app in terms of like not not always impact but like what is actually what i'm finding
there like a lot of times when i'm doing recon it is some random system that does some random weird
functionality that shouldn't exist or shouldn't be exposed and i'm not really understanding like
the core api or the core web app that maybe is using that service somewhere along the way or what
like i'm just seeing oh this is a weird service i can exploit it in this way here's a vulnerability
um and that's very different from like hey on your main web app there's an xss that leads to
account takeover right that's very specific like application level user level type functionality
vulnerabilities versus almost configuration vulnerabilities so they're they're very like
different buckets but they apply to each other very similar where you know it's the same thing of
like you want to understand what you're looking at and you want to be able to like identify like oh
this is a weird target like why does this domain return a blank page instead of a 404 or something
like that and digging into that and identifying where to go from a blank page for a lot of people can be
a lot more difficult than just logging into the web app and clicking all the buttons and finding you know
some endpoint within the js or some functionality within the client side that is is vulnerable um so i think
it's just a very different skill set and it's like when you go to the gym and you do legs versus arms
like it's just a different muscle group and uh you know you can be super jacked uh uh on your on your
on your arms and stuff and then uh you got little twig legs yeah yeah i built a home gym recently and i'm
so struggling it's good to see you see you going after that yeah man i i tend to agree you know i think
it's i think it's just different muscles um muscle groups but it's definitely food for thought of like
i wonder if i'm being intimidated out of the recon game because of the levels of uncertainty but at the
end of the day there's uncertainty with the main app too of like is there going to be anything to find
there um but at least the functionality is there right and that's what i kind of like um the guarantee
that the functionality will be there and there's going to be something for me to work with um whereas
you know in recon there's no guarantees about whether there will be something to work with or not
so yep and even with recon um it's not all the same like there's there's like the recon that nagli
does and like mochan does and then there's the recon that like naffy does or j hatx does where
like for j hatx and naffy that recon is to find new assets for nagli and motion that recon is to exploit
vulnerabilities um like ready vulnerabilities right um and they have like nuclei templates and stuff
like that that are like looking for specific things to pop on these hosts whereas i think
when naffy finds a host that looks interesting he like dives in on it and like goes everywhere just
trying to find some sort of entry point or some sort of thing he's not looking for like
like is this running spring boot and can i can i you know execute this specific cve right it's it's a
bit of a different process um even within just like the recon sphere it is yeah there's there's
definitely like going deep as a whole like go deep for sure keep it simple go deep and and understand
what you're looking at that's a great way to end it man